a grim scene that has come to represent
a country in grip of a major health
crisis
the fires at cremation grounds are
constantly burning
as bodies of those who've died from
covet 19 keep coming
this one in uttar pradesh one of the
state's worst hit by india's second wave
we used to get up to 10 bodies a day now
it has risen to 40 or 50 a day
nationwide the number of new cases has
exceeded 400
000 for four consecutive days bringing
the total number of confirmed infections
at over 22 million about 15 percent of
the cases worldwide
some say those numbers are undercounted
hospitals have been unable to cope with
the crisis a lack of oxygen and beds
continues to [ __ ]
the health care system that's making it
difficult
for many people to get much-needed care
prayam couldn't get treatment in his
hometown
so sick as he is made his way to the
capital new delhi
i really know about the status of the
hospitals of the faridabad you know
directly approach it here and luckily
fortunately i just got
the bed on one shot the government has
recruited
hundreds of former army medics to help
but it's coming under intense public
criticism
for its handling of the situation so far
many wondering why a countrywide
lockdown has not been imposed
like in the early stages of the pandemic
leaving local governments
to impose their own restrictions new
delhi has announced its lockdown will be
extended for a second time
now to may 17th the metro service has
been suspended
and people are only allowed outdoors for
basic necessities
kalakar decided to return home a
thousand kilometers away from the
capital
private company i work for a financial
company that is now shut down because of
the pandemic
i have no choice but to go back to my
village here the situation is very bad
we will be safer there that's the main
reason we're going back
india is the world's leading producer of
coronavirus vaccines
yet most people are unable to get a shot
prime minister narendra modi is also
under pressure to deregulate production
so more doses can be made available in
the country
even though some experts say they can
soon become
ineffective against the indian variant
of covet 19.
hamid al-jazeera